we have to know for some of you guys
your business is growing during good
good or bad times you have to study it
but many times when the business isn't
growing we don't like to study to see
what things we could have done
differently
two weeks ago I got a hold of a book
called How to Mighty Pho how to Mighty
Fall if you guys haven't ordered this
book yet it's an easy book it's four
hours of audible just ordered ordered
the audible and listen to it it's worth
reading anybody's read the book good to
Great who's read the book good to great
it's the same author that wrote good to
great so if you don't know the book it's
good to Great Jim Collins as a legend
how to Mighty Fall there's five things
this author talks about on how to Mighty
Fall five things here's what the five
things are
number one
hubris born of success does anybody know
what this means
hubris born of success means what
follow yourself when you start making
money and you start saying I'm so good
I am so amazing
we did it because we're smarter than
everybody else nobody is as good as we
are and then you start saying well you
know the people it was really all me it
wasn't anybody else I did all of this it
was all me this is because of me all
because of me
and that's a very unattractive quality
when a person gets to this point
the author asks two questions it's a
very interesting question I want your
attention with these two questions
because it has a lot to do with step
number one phase number one he talks
about
he says you have two options on who to
be
two options option number one is to be
the person that says the following we're
winning because we're great
we're the best no one's like us what are
the best at what we do we're smarter
than everybody we work harder than
everybody we're this we're that we have
the best technology we have the bestest
we have the best dad
that's one mindset the second mindset he
says
is when you say look guys we're good
but man I really think we have to
improve our technology or else
guys I think we're solid we have a very
good thing going on here in this system
but I think the other guy's doing it
better I do think we need to improve our
systems a little bit and tighten it up
guys I do think we have that client that
we just closed that's a million dollar
commission but I'm just gonna go stop by
and visit them today in case another
person came and tried to sell them away
from us today I'm gonna go stop by
because I don't know if we 100 have them
I think we have declined 80 but I'm not
convinced we have them 100 percent
guys I think those two sales people that
work for us the two loss I think they're
happy but I'm going to take them to a
restaurant tonight just to make sure
they're happy because I don't I I think
they're locked in but I'm going to take
them out to dinner tonight you got two
mindsets one of them is what
we're the best the other one is what
we're good but I think we got to kind of
I still think we got work to do right
the author says a person who thinks like
this if you are right and you're the
best guess what you kill everybody as a
competitor
but if you're wrong what happens
you're going out of business
then he comes over here and it says this
mindset the person's like I just think
we're not there yet guys I think we got
to do this we're good but I think we got
to improve this we got to call the climb
one more time this mindset he says
if you're right
that's great
if you're wrong that's great
did you get the question on what he's
saying both ways you're better off
betting here a lot of people in the
marketplace were here
the last one two three four five ten
years we're the best we're the best
we're the best hubris born of success
you think it's because of you and you
cannot lose number two
undisciplined Pursuit
of more it's very interesting how we
explain this here
how many of us remembered a company
called Rubbermaid who remembers
Rubbermaid anybody remembers Rubbermaid
so one day Rubbermaid is killing it
they're doing great they're dominating
the marketplace
they all of a sudden say the way we're
going to beat everybody
is we're going to produce and invent one
new product every day for the next three
years
oh my God that's so innovative
every day for three years they produce a
new product
guess what happens three years later
they have a thousand new products but
guess what happened to their company
they don't know how to sell it because
they want 2y too soon they lost their
specialty they lost their focus boom
they took a massive hit the market came
and passed them up during a time like
this a lot of people during scary times
like the one we're in they're gonna try
to say okay let me tell you what we
offer and we offer this and we do credit
repair and we do REO and we do short
sale and we do a loan modification and
we do that and we do this and we do that
we offer this and we offer that they're
gonna go we offer 48 different products
not the right strategy
you're going here you're being tempted
to try to do everybody like you're going
to come to a meeting like this oh we're
going to sell this
oh no no let's do this over here no
let's do this no let's do this let's do
this let's do that momentum's not going
to be created every time you're shifting
and adjusting your philosophies not
strategic number three
number three is denial risk and peril
here's what this is
how many of you guys we've all done this
before but tell me if you relate to this
how many guys look at your data on a
weekly basis you look some kind of data
on a weekly basis if not on a monthly
basis raise your hand if you look at
some data how many guys sometimes
when you're talking to your team
or yourself you only want to look at the
data that makes you look good how many
guys have done that but reason if you've
done that before right we've all done it
before right okay
it'll be like this in a meeting so oh
guys let me tell you what happened do
you know we have a record-breaking
amount of 1003s the applications that
came in and the amount of calls that we
show it's amazing
yeah but we're not fun we're we have we
have to look no no no no let's stay
positive do you realize what's going on
you know how much money we're making
look how much money we're I get it but
customers we're getting 22 percent fewer
customers coming into the restaurant
every day stop being negative do you
realize what we did we have now expand
and open up five more new offices
yeah I I know but dude our our ebitda
just dropped what are we doing our
ebitda just dropped Michael burry who
knows who Michael burry is does anybody
know who Michael burry is how many guys
have no clue Michael berries the moment
I tell you who he is you know who he is
you're going to follow him on Twitter
who's seen the movie Big Short
the guy who predicted it his name is
Michael burry he has an account on
Twitter it's called Cassandra it's him
he's got like six eight hundred thousand
followers go follow him he tweeted
something two days ago he said the
following
how many guys know what the word ebitda
is does anybody know what the word
ebitda means he says how is it that we
have a hundred companies on the market
right now that are worth 10 billion
dollars but their ebitda was minus 100
million dollars the last 12 months
did anybody catch what I just said right
now companies worth 10 billion dollars
but their net profits minus 100 million
he's like is anybody looking at this
stuff
the same thing he said would be short
so this is where people are like no no
but don't look at all the data what
you're supposed to do in this session
here is you're supposed to sit with your
leaders at guys listen
we have to look at these numbers
together because you first sell
everybody on what the vision is long
term not short term
if division is long-term we have to look
at all this data he said the reason why
the Mighty Fall is they do not look at
the data that doesn't make them happy
they don't have the guts to do it number
four let's go to number four
number four is
um
grasping for salvation you know what
stage this is
this is where you're now begging
this is when you all of a sudden you go
to Walmart
you buy a set of knee pads because never
in your life have you prayed this many
times before you're getting on your
knees you you've started praying to to
Prophet Muhammad you're you're praying
to to Jesus you're praying to Abraham
you're praying to every religion you go
from Catholic to Mormonism to
Scientology you're like any God that's
listening to me can one of you guys make
a miracle for me please
you're now begging for salvation
please save me please save us
and what happens next
capitulation to irrelevance or death
do you know what that means
a little bit too many big words for me
as well
does anybody know what capitulation to
irrelevance or death you know what that
means you're gone you're out of business
so now
how many guys are willing to admit to
the following
raise your hand if you're willing to say
I think we went through a little bit of
stage number one how many of you guys
went through a little bit of stage
number one which is kind of like man I
think we're like really really good and
you're like I don't know if we're as
good as we okay by the way all of us are
there all of us are there how many guys
are currently maybe at stage number two
you're like trying a million different
things to try to get so Innovative how
many guys are at stage number three
right now you're like you do not want to
look at the bad numbers you do not want
to look at the bad numbers whatever
stage you're at I'm gonna go back and
tell you the story of animal kahi here's
what animal kahi said animal okay he
started working at Xerox in 1976 as a
salesperson
24 years later and Mulcahy who did sales
for 16 years and for eight years she did
HR and home office the board makes a
decision
to promote and Mulcahy from a Xerox
salesperson
do you know what position
what position do you think they gave her
from a salesperson
a company the size of Xerox do you want
to take a while guess what the position
was you can scream it out what do you
think it was
to the CEO of Xerox what
so she gets the call the board says yep
and
we're announcing as the next CEO of
Xerox you're announcing me as a Knicks
yep you're the next CEO of Xerox oh but
I'm not ready they're announcing it as a
Xerox
okay she's a CEO but we got some news
for you what's that let us tell you what
kind of company you're getting what's
that I'm ready for this this is exciting
I'm gonna become the CEO of Xerox this
is at a time where women are not
becoming CEOs of Fortune 100 companies
this isn't today this is years ago in
2001 August 15th is when she got the
promotional CEO with Xerox
they said here's where the company's at
today
Xerox today we are in debt
debt bonds
we're in debt 19 billion dollars
and she's like okay but how much cash do
we have
we're in debt 19 billion dollars we only
have a hundred million dollars in a bank
account
let me give you some perspective that's
like you have an a hundred and ninety
thousand dollars in credit card and you
only have a thousand dollars in a bank
how many of you guys would be freaking
out right now if that was you and you
got that job that's how she got promoted
to CEO
so she sits there
she's looking at the saying this year
the board tells her we lost 376 million
dollars this year
Moody's does anybody know what Moody's
Grading Company is they graded Xerox
Xerox bonds as junk bonds does anyone
know what a junk bond is like it's trash
don't waste your time don't buy the
bonds of Xerox now how many here know
who Xerox is who knows who Xerox is who
knows who Xerox is how many guys have
bought a product from Xerox before in
your office this is Xerox we're talking
about Xerox about to go out of business
and Mulkey salesperson 26 she's been
with them from 1976 she's a salesperson
day promoter 16 years she's been doing
sales she's now the CEO
they have the first meeting
she gets up and she says
let me tell you guys the story of Xerox
here's who we are here's what we've
overcome here's what we've done here's
why we've won here's what we've done
well here's what we're going to go back
to we're not going through 50 new
products we're not going back to doing
all this stuff we're going to shut this
down it's wasting money we're going to
shut that down we're going to close this
down we're going to go to basic
fundamentals and she went out there
started talking to all of the executive
the employees the sales people lifting
everybody up hey thank you for your work
you're doing such a great job let's keep
getting better thank you for your work
you're doing such a great job let's keep
getting better she kept going to
everybody talking and talking and
talking and talking and talking
two years later or so
they profit a billion dollars four years
later chief executive magazine calls her
the CEO of the Year Forbes
said she is the sixth most powerful
woman in the world
and Mulcahy and she started off as a
regular sales rep for Xerox
what's the point here
what your family right now needs what my
family right now needs what our family
right now needs our company our
Associates people we're working with
it's going back to the basic
fundamentals the future looks bright
long term we're good let me tell you why
we started this company here's why we
started XYZ this is what the vision was
these are our customers how can we help
you look some of you are not going to be
here with us long term I know times are
going to be hard but those of you that
do one day we're going to tell the story
we had one of our guys
in 2010 these guys got started with us
okay they came with us they were with us
for two years when I gave the first
round of equity to our sales guys they
qualify for the second biggest share
when they got this equity
when times got hard they stepped away
year later this is 2012 2013 they
stepped away
when this event took place a few months
ago you know directly you know how much
your exit was supposed to be if I tell
you the number you'd be you'd feel so
bad for those guys
you would feel so bad for them but I
told everybody
listen
times are not going to be always good
we're going to go through some
challenging times it's going to be hard
those of you who stick around with us
long term were going to take over the
world together and this was the constant
language so now Pat what do I do from
here a few things for you to be thinking
about number one you got to initiate new
contact
you have to be a Biz Dev machine today
network card network card network card
send them a gift send them a book be
different when you network with people
don't just go and networking get
people's numbers and try to do business
with them day one become an incredible
networker number two maintain the
current contacts that you have and then
Advance the current contacts that you
have what does that mean maintaining is
hey Johnny how's everything family is
good everybody's good yes fantastic
Johnny how can I help you what are you
going through right now that I can help
you with oh we're good man everything
well you know what I am looking for
somebody that's a great CPA do you know
great accountant Absolutely I'll give
you two options on great accountants in
fact I'm gonna text them to you right a
matter of fact did you get the text yes
these are the two best guys give them a
call I'll call them and let them know
that he should be expecting a call for
him hey thank you so much Patrick no
problem by the way can I ask you a
question yeah I'm looking for a couple
people here to help raise money do you
know any good investment bankers I
should be talking to of course I got one
his name is Jackie fantastic can I get
his name in do you mind sending an email
or group text I'm making an intro most
definitely because I'm initiating new
contacts I'm maintaining my existing
contact and I'm advancing my existing
contact to meet people that they know
this is what you got to be doing the
next three six twelve months
foreign